the power of memory fighting disease
with vaccines and immunization
immunization and vaccination
immunization is an important process
that helps keep people healthy it
protects individuals and communities
from diseases that can be serious and
sometimes even deadly
through the immunization process you
become immune to or protected from a
disease
immunization begins when you receive a
dose of a vaccine which is usually given
with a shot this is known as a
vaccination
search for more information on
medplaneplus.gov about immunization and
vaccination
four vaccines were available people
could only become immune to certain
diseases by catching and recovering from
the actual disease
which was risky since people could get
very ill or die
vaccines have had an enormously positive
impact by preventing disease around the
globe
vaccination is the most effective method
of protecting people from infectious
diseases such as influenza tetanus human
papilloma virus and many the others in
addition vaccines have completely
eradicated smallpox
and have greatly reduced polio in the
world
your immune system and immunization
your immune system is a complex network
of organs tissues cells and chemical
signals that work together to detect and
fight disease-causing germs while your
immune system regularly fights germs on
its own it cannot effectively fight
every germ your body encounters
[Music]
search for more information on
medlineplus.gov about immune system and
disorders
so vaccines are used to mimic an
infection during the immunization
process and help your immune system
learn to recognize specific germs so it
can keep you from getting sick
for more information on medlineplus.gov
about childhood immunization
how vaccines work
vaccines are made from very small
amounts of weak germs dead germs toxins
from germs or parts of germs that can
cause disease because only the actual
germ or its parts can effectively train
your immune system the parts of the
disease causing germs found in the
vaccine that stimulate your immune
system are called antigens
when your health care provider gives you
a vaccine it triggers a complex Cascade
of events in your immune system first a
type of immune cell called an antigen
presenting cell finds and engulfs the
antigen in the vaccine
the antigen presenting cell displays the
antigen on its surface as a signal for
other immune cells to detect
these other immune cells known as T
lymphocytes or T cells recognize the
antigen and become activated and
multiply
at the same time T cells alert other
immune cells known as B lymphocytes or B
cells to the presence of the infection
the B cells then start producing
proteins called antibodies
antibodies recognize and bind to
antigens on germs and infected cells
marking them so that T cells can then
find and destroy them
[Music]
once these steps in the immunization
process are over some of the T and B
cells that were activated go into
hibernation as memory cells Therefore
your immune system remembers the
Infectious germ
and if the same germ infects you later
the memory cells spring into action to
quickly produce antibodies and destroy
the germs before you get sick
[Music]
Community immunity
vaccinating individuals can help keep
your whole Community healthy when enough
people are vaccinated and become immune
to a germ it is harder for The Germ to
spread from person to person so only a
few if any people get infected this is
known as Community immunity or herd
immunity
while Community immunity protects
everyone it is especially important for
protecting people who aren't eligible
for certain vaccines such as infants
elderly people and people with weakened
immune systems
vaccine safety
every vaccine goes through extensive
quality and safety testing and including
multiple clinical trials where vaccines
are tested on healthy people and
vaccines continue to be closely
monitored after they are in use
[Music]
these rigorous scientific procedures
ensure that vaccines are safe and
effective at training your immune system
to protect you from a wide range of
serious infectious diseases
search for more information on
clinicaltrials.gov about vaccine trials
medlineplus offers trusted resources
about immunization and how vaccines can
protect you your family and your
community
start with
medlineplus.gov and find trusted health
information for you
the National Library of Medicine
produced this video